jour de ravitaillement deux ou trois
fois par semaine véronique est informée
sur son téléphone que le distributeur de
viande manque de marchandises là je mets
une pièce de viande a fondu donc très
belles pièces qu'on peut couper comme on
veut pour faire une bonne petite faune
du soin dans le var où dans l'huile ou
faire des brochettes avec par exemple
une quarantaine de produits sous vide
accessible 24 heures sur 24 et 7 jours
sur 7
ici à disposition entre autres des
entrecôtes du rosbif ou encore des
rillettes ne produit pas de la boucherie
au sens et à ce qu'on fait pas de porc
l'autre chose en fait uniquement du
globe de notre solution d'accès vivante
très très spécifique donc en aucun cas
ont fait du tort à boucher qui
voudraient s'implanter si jamais une à
qui il souhaitait on s'en va tout de
suite on laisse la place et pour cause
leur activité principale est à une
vingtaine de kilomètres de là dans le
cher une ferme auberge
elle leur permet d'écouler le reste de
la marchandise les bas morceaux
difficile à vendre aux distributeurs
je vais les valoriser justement sur la
table de la ferme auberge donc je fais
des en ce moment une terrine de
lentilles vertes du berry au boeuf cuit
ça me permet de percer des morceaux
photo feu et après ça moi aussi trouvé
en tant que kristo des idées de recettes
où je vais pouvoir revaloriser tous ces
morceaux là du boeuf de qualité issu à
100 % de leur production
plus d'une centaine de bêtes
aujourd'hui donc sur l'auberge est
proposé que de la charolaise donc
engraisser avec des produits issus à 90
% d'exploitations donc céréales pour la
protéine on travaille avec des féveroles
des luzerne
le distributeur de la vente en direct ou
presque
un nouveau type de circuit court pour
être toujours au plus près du
consommateur